okay everybody um it's you know if you
tell about disruption one of the most
disruptive life you probably get more
cheers from any other single disruption
would be corporations especially bigger
ones the bigger they get the more people
would probably cheer if somebody could
figure out a way to seriously drop them
now true the traditional way you do that
is calling in management consultants and
doing all kinds of other things that are
very costly very expensive another way
might be to tinker with the sort of the
network's comp company at the end of the
day is a kind of a network and you go in
there and you say okay are we doing
anything efficiently and it turns out in
most corporations you're not jive had
the cleverness a decade ago to start
looking at this issue of networking
communications within companies
magically in that ten-year period
someone named Zuckerberg came along and
various other things happen in social
networking suddenly became a big deal
and so these guys were able to hit the
ground running just in time to come up
with a really good solution for how do
you get people in companies to better
align to do what Facebook does for
people inside a company and so I'm going
to shut up and let Chris tell me how
that's wrong and and a few more things
and we'll carry on like that and we'll
just go sir fact I think largely you
have it right i mean the the challenge
for anyone who's ever worked in a large
company is that most the technology was
invented at least 20 years ago it's all
pretty dusty you spend a lot of your
time trying to get your job done and
largely the culture and the people in
the processes have all morphed around
some of the inefficiencies of like
sharepoint yeah that's going to call out
any product that but yeah I mean there's
a lot of things we use every day and
they're there there's difficult to work
with right hard to get information hard
to find people people email is another
place where things are things are buried
and so the whole idea of leveraging
social technologies like what you see in
Facebook and Twitter and all these
places for the enterprise is it doesn't
need to be that difficult
right i mean it should be if you're in a
two hundred thousand person global
organization you should be able to be
connected to the people that can help
you do your job to the expertise you
need to the discussions or the
information you need when you need it
right and I think that's the promise of
social is that it allows an opportunity
to bring the right thing to you at the
right time in context wherever you are
and actually work work around you as
opposed to the other way around now I
mean Facebook and Twitter everybody most
people working in companies these days
are very familiar with doesn't even use
them and there been a lot of issues
about corporation saying or you can't
use facebook you can you can is your
system a kind of closed system where you
have your facebook like thing your
profile like thing your direct messages
like thing or do you actually integrate
into the outside social networking as
well yeah it's a little bit all the
above so I mean we we are a full
platform just like a facebook would be
for your your personal life and people
often ask him get a profile and use your
full profile you've got you can like
things you can share things you can you
can like people in your do you call
somebody you like people in your own
company or you necessarily like people
although you may like people you follow
people you follow yeah but you can like
content or things like so who's got the
most followers in the average typically
the CEO I mean here you're smart and
play you you'll follow the CEO but you
know the as you do all these things is
you author things and you like and you
reading you're right the system learns a
lot about you right so it gets very good
at saying hey Chris I saw that you
really are interested in this did you
know this projects happening over here
did you know someone's already done this
analysis or someone's already looked at
this competitor Oh it'll do that it'll
do that yeah absolutely that's in fact I
would say is that something you have to
accept it like tell me if there's any
dope interesting that's the that's just
from using the platform so if you think
about what Facebook does for us in our
personal lives it largely sort of trade
your personalized information to
websites and things to you know give you
a better experience and then it gets
show social gestures back it uses all
that it learns really deliver better ads
we're not so interested in selling
advertising but we want to get the right
document or the right conversation or
the right person to you at the right
time because that's the part if you're
any one's been a large company that's a
challenge right i mean you spend so much
time repeating what people have already
done just because you can't find it now
one of the things about big companies
that even though we're all one happy
family lots of people don't like each
other don't
our rivalry a lot kind of thing is there
the equivalent of kind of privacy
settings where you can I'll allow other
people in and not these guys yeah the I
think the modern technologies don't just
sort of throw out you know hundreds of
years of culture and the way people
operate we do give the ability you can
have completely private discussions I
could share something just with you a
small group can collaborate on something
that the whole rest of the company would
never know about things that come to
your attention will be anything that
you're allowed to see so most of what
goes on is very public and transparent
and that's pretty disruptive for the
culture right I mean a lot of companies
have not grown up really doing things in
the full sunlight that's why all the bad
behaviors often happen in terms of you
know manager personalities or executive
personalities or employee personalities
I think you know that sort of visibility
ultimately is really good for the
cultures but they go through a lot of
sort of you know challenges as they
transform and change to to a new way of
operating with each other and I mean
friends is the one number i saw
somewhere I think it was News
Corporation which is using this a sixty
percent decrease in the number of emails
internally within the company is that I
mean is that typical or is that yeah
well you know I think for people that do
use this internally and we can be used
externally like t-mobile users for
customer service to engage their
customers but a lot of our customers use
this to pull their culture together a
drop an email is is pretty typical and
it's interesting as well pull into the
outlook inbox right and pull contacts
there so someone emails you see their
profile and you can see so it doesn't
change the email system they're still
using outlook they can but then if
you're in jive and I think a lot of
folks who who make a switch to a social
platform you you learn that it's a
little bit better right i mean because
if you think about an email i send a
copy over to you you send a copy to me
it could apply to another 5,000 people
in the organization they'll never see it
unless we happen to forward it to them
and if we leave the company and our
inbox kind of dies with us in a social
platform the people really go to the
communication right so you and I could
you know really have a great
conversation get to a great decision
maybe you go to your next opportunity I
leave later someone else can still kind
of enter that and understand why we did
what we did all this context stays with
the company which has been a huge
challenge right it's really hard for new
plays experience this all the time right
they get in the company and they're just
like oh my god I'm even know where to
start okay so collaboration is one big
meme another is the kind of open company
that has a sort of continuum of
relationships not just within the
company but also with its own customers
and suppliers and all that this system
might if i remember right all works that
all works too right that's right so I
mean our premise from day one was social
technologies are fantastic for
connecting people turns out people our
customers and they are employees and
they are partners I mean we don't think
it's just about you know employees
working together or vice versa and a lot
of the disruption entering the
enterprise now I mean all you hear
clouds social mobile big data all the
buzz words it's been very empowering for
all these entities right I mean
customers now really expect companies to
come to them well like tip I think you
mentioned that the the nike+ guys we
heard from earlier today they're using
this that's right they're very well how
do what's that for what's how does that
work but they basically created this was
very smart they created this platform
they incorporated the nike+ sort of
running shoe which allowed people who do
these virtual runs against each other
kind of like fight club but for running
run club and you know it really got
people excited right because they were
able to engage with other people they
were able to share their runs motivate
each other and the thing they found was
because they tracked it all the way
through they actually got you know north
of thirty-five percent of folks wearing
other shoes to convert over to Nike
brand so they could have that experience
and and so they were smart because they
really interwove their social strategy
in with their business strategy not
everyone is is this matter are they
using jive all through the company is
that they've used this internally as
well for some of their their digital
management but they don't use this
throughout the entire company so how do
I mean I mean like when you mean by the
you guys are big your public company you
want public in John you're in
january-september that's right okay you
play with the big dogs I think your
targets are I mean when you come into a
cub do you like come into news
corporation with a memo to all employees
or is it do you come inside doors back
doors how do you typically come in all
the above you know when you talk about
something that changes the way an entire
culture can operate right i mean that
that happens in a few different ways and
you can't separate out the technology
and the culture i mean some people
they'll talk about all the technologies
important but it is and other people
will say well the technology is going to
solve everything and it won't so we've
had customers come tops down you know
the border CEO will say we really need
to transform the way we're perceived and
transform our company and and that works
right we have other folks where you know
maybe a really progressive team lead
will say you know what my company really
is kind of stodgy and it's hard and IT
you know takes six months to respond to
a helpdesk ticket so they'll just start
something up to the cloud and start
working and often as they get that going
other parts of the company see it and
then it'll spread and it can it can work
all of those ways and then how do you
how do you how do you guys make money we
charge per user so you know and when a
company brings us in I mean one of the
things that separates us from a lot of
the noise out there as we've always said
look if we're not providing business
value you know then don't pay us right
it's very clear we don't need to give a
free version or anything like that we
really believe that we can help you get
your job done more effectively and help
you prove out the numbers in the metrics
and so we do charge per user per year in
the case of you know some of these more
external facing sites like you know say
mcafee or tmobile or something like that
then we'll charge by page view trunch
but we charge for it by sorry Paige geez
so you know similar to the way people to
websites okay it about because they're
mostly yeah it for outward right so Sony
got a war right i mean there's a lot of
folks i don't know if you've ever gone
on a site like that you look like a
gamer but you get there and and you know
it's like a lot of people are anonymous
right and not the hackers but they
literally just don't have kind of the ID
and so in those cases we'll do it on how
much the platforms getting used not
every specific user and for the classic
internal use big company watery two
hundred dollars a year thousand dollars
a year about it's about a hundred
dollars per user per year 100 also use
your year so that that's a pretty I mean
in the big scheme of things that's not a
vast amount to the IT guys is I mean it
no not in the big scheme of things if
you look at a platform like Salesforce o
build charge per license like you know
north of sixteen hundred dollars per
user so it said I mean again you you
kind of have to get in there and weighed
against the value you get right i mean
how when you you've hired all these like
well-educated super smart people that
you know went through college and
master's degrees to kind of do this job
and then you stick in the room and give
them a bunch of systems
don't operate very well it's like it's a
pretty small amount to get more
effectiveness I mean in some ways it's
funny because it's it's a pretty
flexible system and it sounds I mean
from what I do you see people do you
watch use cases in your customers and
find people using it in ways that you
may nay not even originally have
anticipated do you get that or it mean I
mean everyone's use like SharePoint or
alphagan where it's kind of its just
there you deal with it or you don't can
do people have more flexibility with
yours there's a lot of flexibility and
this space is transforming all the time
I mean social platforms in the
enterprise I think are evolving much
more quickly than they ever have before
we learn we learn things constantly and
I think because it's a people-centric
system pretty much if people are
involved they're using the platform in
some way we're starting to understand
much more the value we provide I mean
there's been a lot of confusion of like
if something spinning off an activity
stream it must be social an exhibit
extreme is largely noise right i mean if
you don't want to know that thing and it
comes at the wrong time it's distracting
to you so this is like a twitter-like
thing right I mean so you know you hear
a lot of folks are like okay great that
account flows or these things or
somebody chats about their dog and
interesting but now we can trying to get
your job done and so a lot of where
we've invested is what they call kind of
social graph analytics and so that's
basically how do we make sure that this
thing is interesting for you at that
time right and it's really a
personalized contextual experience and
not you know one size fits all for
everybody in some ways it sounds like a
kind of a HR dream or nightmare
depending on which seat you're sitting
in in the sense that suddenly your
company has one place where they can
look at everything you're doing and they
can compare you and your activity with
the guy on the next cubicle and his
activity I mean it is that is that part
of the package I think that's right i
mean i guess largely when you say to our
dream or nightmare it depends on the
vision of your company in your culture i
mean if you're trying to build a culture
where everybody takes orders and and
does the same process over and over i
mean largely you know i'm sure some
speaker today we'll talk about how
you'll be replaced by a robot if you're
doing what people are good at then you
know i think you want to make things
more visible i mean smart people are
able to absorb information to make
decisions and so i think we're seeing
that shift people come in to to get
their first job now and they're used to
having a while
of information at their fingertips it's
not this game of like I know more than
you do it's really I have to I have to
engage you as an equal even if you work
for me because you know you're smart and
you can make good decisions do you get
the CIO type sort of a security minded
one saying things like wait a minute we
don't really want to give Johnny over
here the keys the potentially the keys
to the thing over there I mean that you
becomes an issue right it's absolutely
an issue and I'd separate even out
security from some of the technology
issues I mean if you look at the arc of
the enterprise of the role of the CIO I
mean back in the 90s and the height of
innovation disruption that was the
bubble you saw the CIO role get created
and it was very strategic right it was
enabling businesses to transform be more
competitive and somewhere along the
lines they turned into policemen and
gatekeepers and the guys to keep the
systems up and man the help desk and I
think now that a lot of this innovation
is coming in again and candidly like
people are walking devices through the
front door they're firing up cloud
systems without asking for permission
largely in many cases are out of
compliance the role the CIO is shifting
again and I think it's a good shift
where they're starting to recognize
these trends are changing the role to be
a more strategic role again they can
enable the enterprise to be more
effective and more agile we try to do a
lot of things to keep you know I tea and
CIO in control while still giving all
the users you know the freedom and the
ease of use their used to in their
personal lives so maybe we can maybe if
you guys really get some traction we can
add like a point of GDP all those emails
that are getting and just endless too
many meetings too many emails too many
ccs get rid of them all and we can go
back to having a healthy and happy
economy let's see I mean that's a dream
and I think it I think largely it's not
just a dream i think the promise is
really there and we've seen this way
before I mean when portals came in the
promise was we'd be able to find
everything we needed and then intranets
and and wave after wave but it really
does seem now now that the technology is
really morphing around you know the way
we operate and now that we can really do
analytics at scale and understand what
you're doing not forcing you to kind of
like enter in something in a profile or
tag things or classify things or upload
things once the technology gets out of
the way and we've heard this a few times
I think Jack Dorsey keep saying that
you know that's where people are happy
right it's it's supposed to enable you
it's not supposed to be something you
need to learn just so you can do your
job thank you very much we are out of
time Chris meraas from jive and I hope
everybody gets more job thank you thanks
Fetzer thank you